أول شيء تريد القيام به هو مجرد
إلقاء نظرة حول هل
تبدو منطقة البار مزدحمة للغاية ،
وماذا عن
المسافة المادية للطاولات إذا كان أي
منها يمثل مشكلة ،
فمن المحتمل أن تخرج ثانيًا
أرتدي قناعين ، من الواضح أنني لن
أرتدي القناع عندما أتناول الطعام ، لكنك
ستواجه صعوبة في الحفاظ على
مسافة جسدية ، لذا ارتدِ القناع
واذهب إلى الحمام ، أي شيء
لديك قناع أنا وواحد  من بين
هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين يحملون
معقم اليدين معي في كل مكان أذهب إليه ،
ربما يجب عليك ذلك أيضًا إذا كان
مطعمك يحتوي على قائمة طعام عبر الإنترنت ، تحقق من
ذلك مسبقًا مما سيقلل
من عدد الأسطح التي يجب أن
تلمس شيئًا واحدًا في هذا المطعم  هو
أنهم يقومون بالتطهير بين كل
عميل يأتي شخص ما
يمسح الطاولة ويمسح الكراسي إذا
لم يفعلوا ذلك ، فقد ترغب في
إحضار مناديل خاصة بك إن أمكن وتفعل
ذلك بنفسك إذا كان بإمكانك تناول الطعام في
الخارج  ستكون مفضلًا وأكثر أمانًا أيضًا ،
لكن هذا ليس ممكنًا دائمًا ، لذا إذا
كنت جالسًا بالداخل ، فحاول التفكير في
العثور على طاولة ليست في
منطقة مرورية كثيفة ، فتناول الطعام لساعات إذا
استطعت واحتفظ بهذه النقطة أيضًا في الاعتبار على
اتصال وثيق  تم تعريفه من قبل
شخص على بعد ستة أقدام ولكن أيضًا
لمدة 15 دقيقة أو أكثر ، فهذه هي
أنواع التعرضات التي تريد تجربتها
وتقليلها الآن من الواضح أنك لا تستطيع تناول الطعام
باستخدام قناع ، أريد أن أذكر الناس
بأن هذا ليس  مرض منقول بالغذاء
لا أستطيع الحصول على مناعة الفيروس من
استنشاقه ، فنحن نلمس عينيك
أنفك أو فمك ، لذا يجب أن
يكون هذا آمنًا ويجب
أن تذهب الآن إذا كنت ستخرج لتناول الطعام ،
فمن الأفضل تناول الطعام معه
عائلتك ، وحدة عائلتك ، إذا كنت
ستخرج مع أشخاص
لم ترهم منذ فترة ، فلديهم فكرة عما إذا
كانوا يقومون بعمل جيد في
الحفاظ على سلامتهم لأن الطريقة التي
يتصرفون بها ستؤثر عليك
[  موسيقى]